sehr heiß diskutierte moment was hältst
du von der agentur ja gut ein bisschen
ausführlicher beantworten richtig cool
oder was geht hier ist organi und hitze
gibt es ein rädchen 82 beginnt
wahrscheinlich drei münchen nicht nur
3000 ist der computer dynamik kompressor
seinen dienst zu übersteuern nicht viel
spaß ja wir spielen acht asg und es gibt
ein paar freaks mit hashtag affen
schreiben endlich auf 8 kanal ich denke
so was ist richtig behindert worüber
würden sich leute am meisten wundern
wenn es in die trends kommt und dann
dachte ich so ein hashtag affen
schreiben
ich lese die branche media aus meinen
lieblings zufall dass rolf dass sie vor
der tür stand aber es lässt sich
natürlich gut
ich habe schon öfters die frage gelesen
von wegen streams die frage ernsthaft
beantworten werde swisscom diese fragst
du so ernsthaft 5 gehörte ihm hat mir
schon kleine abnahmen versucht hat ihr
aber nur musik im hintergrund dafür sagt
nein wert nicht aber ich denke mal wenn
ich richtig zeit habe dann werden zu
viele aber es ist halt immer so ich
meine wenn ich mal abends uns zu tun
habt dann passiert es auch dass ich mich
einfach ist da oben hat ja dann passiert
es halt öfters dass ich mich einfach mal
spontan freunden verabredet oder sowas
und das könnte ich nicht machen wenn ich
so sagen will hier raus kommt jetzt
jeden spaß tag im stream
und darauf habe ich halt echt keinen
bock sodass ich dass mir diese freiheit
da ja dass du mir die abgeltung homo und
deshalb ist es halt so eine sache mit
dem streams nächste frage bist du
momentan mit seinem leben zufrieden oder
nicht und wenn nicht was würdest du
ändern
also ich würde ändern dass neben mir
sitzt aber sonst nichts zufrieden kein
spaß ist derart heruntergekommen
ich war hier noch nie hier oben in
meinem leben ich glaube auch die map
offensichtlich geändert
man konnte nämlich vorher ein home bojan
ja nie mein komponist fragt ob ich
seinen punkt markiert einen richtigen
landregen
ja ich mag das
neben mir dass uns ein paar local guides
der geisterfahrer homeboys auf twitter
und der gerade vorgestellte ab jetzt
studiert dann lieber bratwurst oder
größer kleinwagen kommt gar nicht so ok
dann geht's nach italien
wenn ihr das seht bin ich behaupte ich
mal schon da als alternative vom bogen
rumpf erwischt sagt okay jetzt kannst du
dann kommen ein freund
oder vielleicht auch nicht und noch ein
alter wie flac mir das denke ich schon
3000 meter davon weg
eine interessante frage wann der markt
oder warum kommt kein markt mehr welche
ist nicht mag
ich weiß es nicht ich habe den start
verpasst und das ist wie bei so vielen
sachen wenn man wenn man dann irgendwann
mal raus ist dann fängt immer schwerer
wieder reinzukommen und dann hat man
keinen bock und ja eigentlich was finde
ich richtig doofe mir selbst dass ich
das nicht gross weiter geführt habe aber
es ist nunmal partie gewesen
was würdest du würdest du dich
entscheiden glück liebe oder geld geld
die post im animod auf jeden fall also
wenn mappus und mit dabei werden dann
wirklich fürs geld entscheiden
pixel
ich hoffe doch die zwei hits und feuer
hatte
er hatte sich dafür eingesetzt ok ich
jetzt so was von daun junge aber wie
knapp weil ich habe es gegeben gut
gegeben ist okay gute frage sehr heiß
diskutiert im moment was hältst du von
der agentur gute bisschen ausführlicher
beantworten richtig wiedersehen
also du kannst ja noch ändern meint zu
sein denn touristin sache als ich
weisheit nicht ich weiß von einigen
leuten von den gangstern dass die als
krasse was bieten so also das ist übel
drauf haben julien beim zum beispiel war
ich richtig finde auch cave hat
musikalisches talent und sowas aber
gibt's seit leute wo ich mich fragt was
sie auf der bühne machen ich habe mir
jetzt noch keinen vollen auftritte etwas
reingezogen
aber ich frage mich was macht da geht
was macht dagegen auf der bühne so ich
habe nur so 1000 bilder schon gesehen
und wie auf instagram wo da die und
leihen sich küssen so auf der bühne und
ich denke mir so alter ist es jetzt teil
des gescripteten programms steht da drin
küsst euch bei minuten sonst was ist
ehrlich ich stelle mir vor wie krass das
wäre wenn da irgendwie in wien programm
drin steht wann die sich küssen müssen
wie sie kisten müssen
das finde ich richtig krass also an sich
finde ich nicht mal so falsch meinen
solange die ticketpreise fair sind
ja habe ich auch schon gehört ich mein
wenn man jetzt so sich überlegt im
verhältnis dazu der zirkus vielleicht
die karte was ich zu 10 10 20 euro
aber ein zirkus es auch nicht so berühmt
ist das scheißegal ich weiß nicht ja
also es wird auch natürlich krasser
scharf kritisiert aber ich finde ich
wichtig hat war zum ersten mal möglich
verbreitet
ja von daher ich finde es schon also man
könnte die ticketpreise ein bisschen
niedriger machen aber ich kann halt
wirklich schlecht sagen ob das klappt
ist oder nicht
im endeffekt ist wichtig dass die leute
dies mögen die dort hingehen dass sie
zufrieden nach hause geben solange das
gewährleistet ist und die dabei dafür
nicht irgendwie krass ausgebeutet werden
also was geht es mir eigentlich auch
recht gut vorbei ich mein ich muss mir
nicht anschauen
ich will es mir nicht anschauen und
lustige frage gewesen
wir haben dich und jobs kennen gelernt
dass justin und ich haben uns
kennengelernt
die fans habe ich es kommt schon vor
dass man sie verschreibt
also justin und ich haben uns
kennengelernt
ich meine sogar dass ich das denn damals
gar nicht cool fand sowas und irgendwie
habe ich mich haben wir dann doch mal
aufgenommen und dann dann haben wir
sofort gut verstanden also wir haben
halt so festgestellt dass die uns mögen
als wir so einen gemeinsamen nenner
hatten diesen diese antoine sprache und
so was wie wir beide hält kreis gefeiert
haben immer ja da habe ich gemerkt wie
sehr ich dich lieben
hast du auch mal vor so kleine riege vor
götz unterstützen faktisch heftig mit
ihnen videos backslash weil die bank
nicht herz schlägt verstanden ja ich hab
da ist kein klassisches format um sowas
vorgesehen aber mein wenn man
zurückschaut ich hab schon tatsächlich
den einen oder anderen unterstützt
zuerst natürlich aus meinem umfeld mein
bruder zum beispiel
aber ich meine auch medium habe ich zum
beispiel auch immer stress weil ich halt
einfach kraft fanden fällt einfach krass
fand was er ja was er so gemacht hat wie
gut im pvp waren das okay der boj hat
verdient dass man ihnen forscht und ja
er macht natürlich ein paar kontroverse
sachen unser guter chancen aber an sich
fand zeit heftig sowie gute essen man
wenn man sich auf wenn man sich was ich
auf sich auf sich aufmerksam macht und
das drauf hat dann bin ich da auch der
letzte der sagt nein du darfst nicht
berührt werden und gut dann spreche ich
jetzt aus dieser welt weil zehn minuten
pro weinheim wir hatten wir da vorne
viel runde
ich wollte schon so auf abmoderation
machen aber dann wäre es dir
wahrscheinlich drei minuten lang oder so
was mal zehn minuten dachte ich wäre
eine gute zeit aber wahrscheinlich habt
ihr deutlich weniger gesehen wissen ok
dann fragte mich nicht die richtige
frage fußballerinnen würdest du jemals
eine schublade typveränderung machen
heißt was wäre bei mir total
typveränderung wahrscheinlich komplett
stärker kurz rasierte blonde haare oder
sowas kurz rasierte haare
das würde jetzt gerne blonde glas
kurz rasiert nicht ich weiß ja ich würde
würde das nicht dauerhaft machen wollen
glaube ich also ich weiss nicht dafür
nicht
nein ich weiß echt nicht also ich glaube
ich mal was ich gut finde ist so ein
bisschen rum experimentieren mal was
anderes zwischenwertung gehen also müsst
also wohl lieber ski ablenken kann gehen
das ist nicht wichtig was siehst du
deshalb hast du auch einigermaßen chance
weil halt überall weiß wo die kiste
weißt du noch verbessert haben über den
dubiosen einsatz des high-end
ausgerüstet und michel bastos und
weggefährte high und ausgerüstet
ausgelöst
interessante frage wenn du in einer
youtuber wickelt würdest wie wäre es
also wohl nur youtube sind dann
natürlich mein bruder ich weiß nicht
siehst du als youtuber falls ja dann du
auch so einen kanal also aktiv und
famous seien bisher nicht
dann will ich auf jeden fall mit mit
sturm waffe würde ich eine bude ziehen
auch wenn natürlich der
altersunterschied der relativ groß ist
ich glaube das stimmt 22 23h ist es
natürlich hinter uns ja gesagt
ok ok ich hab natürlich noch vor allem
vogel verdienten applaus
die leute bisher so läuft sondern bei
mir okay für mich der spaß ganz spontan
würde ich auch mit mit jona würde ich
irgendwo mit gutes team war ich habe
mich mega gut auf anhieb verstanden
jonas scholz aber also den pc nicht
korrekt integriert
ansonsten gibt einige leute die ich dich
cool finden also aber halt eine wg ist
schon krass
also da wird ja eigentlich nur mit dem
mit dem engeren kreis also ihr wisst ja
auch selbst mit wem ich aufnehmen mit
wenig so gefahren bin
eine interessante frage seine single
stellichte nein ich will keine fragen
von dieser schreibt mir die auftritte
mit hersteller verstecken schrei in
welchen dann würdest am liebsten leben
ich wollte am liebsten
lambrecht in deutschland also was bis zu
deutsch ich bin zufrieden mit
deutschland wieder die zufrieden und wir
haben keinen nationalstolz und das alles
nur wegen adolf nachteil schöne scheiße
der typ war doch eigentlich in
österreich erkennt man die schicksale
praxis.de ist natürlich crazy der boj
richtig begonnen hätten wie wird knapp
drei runden gewonnen oder eine die erst
habe ich verloren oder die zweite habe
ich auch dass man auf der karte
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wenn ihr
mich süß findet dann schlagt raul